we have a voicemail number but today
instead of a voicemail I have an email
from a viewer that I want to read to you
by the way please send me your pictures
wearing david pakman show gear with
david pakman show coffee with your david
pakman show coffee mugs or bumper
stickers or whatever we want to start
publishing some of those to our social
media david at david pakman.com ok if
you have any david pakman show gear
photograph yourself with it send it to
me david at david pakman.com so we can
put it on social media okay Leslie wrote
to me Leslie says I think the American
people should not have to pay federal
taxes during a government shutdown of
any kind Trump needs to feel the sting
of his actions financially regards
Leslie that is a double-edged sword
on the white on the one hand it's true
that it seems sort of incoherent that we
have the government shutdown and a whole
bunch of government and money is not
being spent on programs because of the
shutdown but everybody still has to pay
the exact same amount of federal taxes
that seems sort of incoherent it's also
kind of incoherent how the anti-tax
right that has positions ranging from
it's your money and you should get to
keep as much of it as possible all the
way to the extreme cartoonish
libertarian view of taxes are illegal
they are not making this argument when
it's at least Donald Trump that has shut
the government down which further
exposes the lack of coherence and the
fact that this is merely a political
ploy period but there are real
consequences to the shutdown and I
actually you know me Pat I am NOT one of
these anti-tax for the reason for no
reason other than just being anti-tax
Crusaders but I do think that there is
something to Leslie's idea that the
government's not spending money if
government functions aren't actually
being carried out that's why we pay
taxes why does everybody have to keep
paying their tax rate at the same their
taxes at the same rate we've talked
about how there's really no sense of
urgency during government shutdowns
because only like what are the 15
percent of the government shuts
down military keeps operating people
still get their social security checks
all that stuff if you were to shut down
some of those services I think that the
government would open up right away and
similarly if people were to stop paying
their taxes I think the same thing would
happen there is no doubt whatsoever and
this is why if if we're really shutting
down government then maybe it should
really get shut down and that would
probably prevent shutdowns from
happening in the future with this
frequency we've got a great bonus show
for you today we'll talk about Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer demanding equal
time in parallel to Donald Trump's
commandeering of American television for
the purposes of scaring people about the
non-existent undocumented immigrant
crisis we'll talk about much more all of
that on today's bonus show